what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
as you can see by the title I want to
talk about some things Dan and Dave kind
of forgot to answer before Game of
Thrones ended about a year ago right
before the final season aired I made a
few videos where I listed some of the
things I hope they would answer before
it was all said and done now I will
admit they did give us some answers even
if we did not like them but we were not
given any closure for most of the things
I listed in those videos if you have
been a subscriber of mine for over a
year you might actually remember those
videos I made in one video I talked
about a handful of the different
unsolved mysteries in Game of Thrones
that still needed answered in another
video I listed a handful of the
characters that vanished from the story
who still needed some form of closure I
want to go back and look at those videos
then like I said at the beginning I want
to talk about some things Dan and Dave
forgot to answer before Game of Thrones
ended what did they actually leave out
that could have made this a better story
if included let's talk about it number
one where was Howland Reed as you all
know Howland Reed is the father of Jojen
and Meera Reed but he was also one of
ned stark's most loyal friends that's my
father
beside him is Howland Reed Mira's father
this is one of many very important
characters that we never actually saw in
the current story the only time we saw
Howland Reed was during one of brain
Starks flashback scenes at the Tower of
joy that seemed provided an answer that
millions of fans were wanting to know
for decades and that of course was the
identity of Jon Snow's mother since Ned
Stark died before he could ever reveal
the truth about John's parents Howland
Reed was one of the characters fans were
hoping would show up to reveal that
information
now although brain stark was able to do
this on his own it would have made for a
really great scene if Alan Reed would
have shown up to confirm the truth to
Jon and everyone else for that matter
some of you might not know this but the
author george RR martin has one on
record saying Howland Reed will
absolutely show up in the current story
in the books most likely to reveal some
very important information
not only does Howland Reed know the
truth about Jon Snow
he may also know some things about the
White Walkers you see when Alan Reid was
much younger he wanted to seek out some
additional knowledge so he went to the
gods I in search of the green men he
ended up spending an entire winter there
the Allah faces is famously known for
being the location where the first men
in the children of the forest met to
agree to end their years of fighting
with each other this is also one of the
only places in the South that still have
weirwood trees and children of the force
so there's no telling how much
information Howland Reed learned while
he was there doesn't this sound like a
fascinating character that should be
included at the end of the story he
could have made the final season so much
more interesting but Dan and Dave must
have forgot while Danny kind of forgot
about they aren't fleet and Hurons
forces they certainly haven't forgotten
about her and they're just waiting for
her to come back number two what
information was inside Sam's books when
Sam and Gilly were traveling to Old Town
for Sam to become a maester Sam said the
main reason for him going there was so
he could learn as much information as
possible to help John for when the time
came to defeat the White Walkers I said
that because I mean even little Sam to
be safe that's all I want
to become mr. song can help John when
the time comes well as soon as Sam gets
there we see him looking at the books in
the restricted area hoping to find some
much-needed information that could help
them we even saw Gilley reading a book
about the long night legends of the long
night
now unfortunately no one at the Citadel
wanted to believe Sam about the threat
beyond the wall this is what led Sam to
leaving before he could even become a
maester since he can all get the help
that he needed he decided to take things
into his own hands Sam and Gilly left
old town in the middle of the night but
not before Sam took a bunch of old books
and documents with him most of us did
assume those books had to contain some
crucial information about how to defeat
the White Walkers but we never got to
see what was inside them in fact Sam did
not tell John any helpful information
about the White Walkers when he returned
to Winterfell so you have to wonder why
did they show Sam taking all these
things if they weren't gonna come into
play later these old books could have
been the key to Dan and Dave giving us
some answers to gameofthrones greatest
mysteries but once again they must have
forgot while Danny kind of forgot about
they aren't fleet and Euron's forces
they certainly haven't forgotten about
her and they're just waiting for her to
come back number 3 whatever happened to
quake this is another one of the most
interesting and mysterious characters
from Game of Thrones and A Song of Ice
and Fire for those of you that don't
know Quaithe is from the shadow lands
beyond the scheie which just so happens
to be the same location
Illyrio said Daenerys his dragon eggs
were from as well as Melisandre now
although this character wasn't in very
many scenes I know it was someone not
was dying to see again but she just
vanished from the story based on her few
scenes she did seem to support Daenerys
but we really did not know her true
intentions we betray her again Jorah the
Andal
will you betray her again neva India
Song of Ice and Fire books she talks to
Danny about some of the prophecies that
have yet to be revealed this has always
made me wonder what her end game is what
else does she have in store for Daenerys
Targaryen does she really want to see
Danny succeed or are her intentions more
sinister than we thought
the only way this will be answered now
is if it happens in the books because
Dan and Dave kind of forgot to bring
this character back into the story while
Danny kind of forgot about they aren't
fleet and Hurons forces they certainly
haven't forgotten about her and they're
just waiting for her to come back number
4 what was Jack and agar really up to
this is something fans have wanted
answered ever since the character was
introduced again this is another one of
those fascinating in mysterious
characters from Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire
we made Jack and agar all the way back
in the second season when Arya Stark and
ginjury are travelling to the wall with
the other recruits for the Nights Watch
he was brought with them from King's
Landing somehow this ninja assassin
wound up in the black cells right under
the red key at the same exact time as
Ned Stark I find this very interesting
because Jack and agar does not seem like
the type of character that would allow
themselves to get captured unless they
wanted it to happen
why was he down there anyway and why did
he immediately take interest in Arya
Stark you're caught Ari
this menace the honor to be jaqen haka
this does not seem like a coincidence to
me it's almost as if all of this was set
in motion before Ned Stark was
eventually killed
now some fans say he might have even
traded faces with Ned Stark
Syrio Forel and even Rhaegar Targaryen
but Game of Thrones never revealed any
of this you have to wonder what were his
true intentions for Arya Stark because
the faceless men have a very different
agenda in the books you see Jack and
gore is not the character that is
training Arya at the house of black and
white in the books Jack and actually
goes to the Citadel undercover as
someone else while there he does come
into contact with Samwell Tarly and
Marwan damage an arch maester of the
Citadel now since he's at the Citadel we
have to assume he's there to kill
someone in particular or to find out
some information that has yet to be
revealed one of the most interesting
things is that jaqen steals a key that
opens every door at the Citadel this
will give him access to those same books
in the restricted area that we saw same
wall Tarly take with him but again you
have to wonder why wasn't any of this
explored in Game of Thrones Dan and Dave
could have taken a character like Jack
and a gar in so many different
fascinating directions but I guess they
kind of forgot to give this character
his own storyline an interesting ending
while Dany kind of forgot about they
aren't fleet and Hurons forces they
certainly haven't forgotten about her
and they're just waiting for her to come
back number five who is the night king
now this is the one I was wanting
answers to the most the night king is
another character shrouded in mystery
he is the supreme leader in creator of
the White Walkers a force that was
introduced in the opening scene of the
very first episode not only was he the
greatest threat Westeros has ever known
but his magical abilities seem to be
growing with each passing season
although the White Walkers were
introduced in the beginning we did not
meet their leader until the fourth
season when we saw him create a white
Walker out of one of Craster's sons ever
since then we saw him continue to grow
his army by the thousands and we knew
there would come a day when Westeros
would have to face this threat head-on
based on the little information given
from the books we knew the White Walkers
had some very close ties to House Stark
according to old man
the original night's King was a member
of House Stark who would eventually be
slain by his own brother
the stark of Winterfell but none of this
was ever explored in Game of Thrones
either thanks to the three-eyed Raven
and brain stark we finally saw how the
night king was created during a
flashback but we never did find out who
the man was
I've always wondered where did he come
from and why was he chosen to lead an
army of ice demons set out to destroy
all of humanity you made the white
leaders were being slaughtered our
sacred trees cut down did he already
have some magical abilities before he
became the night King did he happen to
come from a very special bloodline the
night king and the White Walkers were
built up as the most dangerous threat
since the opening episode but they were
completely wiped out by the poke of a
dagger before any of these questions
were answered why Dan and Dave why the
night Kings character and backstory
could have went in so many interesting
directions but once again Dan and Dave
kind of forgot how to write one while
Danny kind of forgot about they aren't
fleet and Hurons forces they certainly
haven't forgotten about her and they're
just waiting for her to come back now
these are only a handful of things that
were never answered before Game of
Thrones ended but we all know there were
so many more things left out of the show
they could have easily made more
episodes and even seasons for that
matter if only they would have included
some of these things but I look forward
to the topics getting explored at great
lengths in the books anyways let me know
your thoughts down below what storylines
do you wish Dan and Dave would have
included before the end what did they
leave out that you really wanted answers
to I'm interested in reading what you
have to say I want to thank all of you
for watching the video as always I
really appreciate that I hope to see
everyone come back for the next video
have a great day bye
[Music]
[Music]
you